And we're live.
>> Hey, everybody.
Today, Jordan and
I will be going, hello, Jordan.
We're going to be going over how to
go from a mockup to a full website.
Full website here being HTML and CSS.
So basically how to take
to start from an idea and
a design, and put it into actual code so
that it can be visible to
the web just in HTML and CSS.
Obviously, you could probably
also just make an image of it and
put it on a some interesting
website error, but
that's not really what
we're looking to do here.
So to start with,
I suppose we can go into, mockups are
generally used because it's easier to
design a mockup than it is to just
start coding and try to make a website.
So you generally have
either a group of people or
a person whose job it is to
actually make mockups there.
That is after all more art
than technical skills.
And then from there you give it
to a front-end web designer and
they would start actually making
it into an actual website.
>> And
yeah if you want to do this yourself,
there's a bunch of different
tools you can use to do mockups.
You can make them in Photoshop,
it's pretty common.
You can make them,
there is a software called Balsamiq,
you can also make mockups there.
What are some, do you have any other
ideas of what to use to make mockups?
>> Some people actually
use literal paper.
>> Yeah, paper's a good one too.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Forgot about that.
>> But, and they might actually cut
things out and sort of make it human.
Think of it as arts and crafts, that's
sort of like what they actually do.
>> Yeah.
>> And then-
>> But for their redesign they actually
cut out little pieces of paper and
use that as their design mockups.
So it's, you know, everybody uses it.
>> So
that that's what we'll be doing today.
We'll actually be using the same mockup
that you might have seen in class.
So just to show that here,
Miguel screen share.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So this is actually what
I was doing right now.
This is the mockup that we'll be using.
So Udacity symbol up top, name, but this
is basically supposed to be a resume
type of thing unless you're showing off
some featured work with some images.
The mockup is actually just the portion
to the right of this white space.
This is just designating which
colors are going to be used.
These are how the colors look.
These are the actual color hex.
What's the actual word for
that I don't know, I'm forgetting.
>> What?
>> The word for the hex, the hex colors.
Is it hex colors?
>> Hex decimal codes?
>> Yeah, It's just a code for
the colors.
>> Right.
>> So that's what we will be trying
to do here, and we'll do it more or
less from scratch.
So let's open up Sublime and go.
So the two main things we'll be using
here are Sublime and the browser,
since we'll be opening it up
in our browser quite often.
So let's screen share Sublime.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So what we'll be doing here, hopefully
everyone can see that very blank screen.
>> [INAUDIBLE] Yeah, I can see it.
>> Okay.
So what we'll be doing here is first
we'll just make an HTML file since
that's what will be using with it.
Sorry, I'm resizing everything,
making the font a little bit bigger.
So, first we'll save this.
We'll do it, and I think this
is my blank thing right here,
or some other blank thing right here.
And we'll just call it
a webpage Because I'm
really talented when
coming up with names.
So just webpage.html,
so I should be able to just type in
HTML and it sort of fills in the very,
very basics with me for Sublime
because I installed the HTML autofill.
>> I've never seen that before.
So what, you just type HTML and
press Enter?
>> Tab, but yeah.
>> Cool.
>> You can, if you want to look into how
to make Sublime work like that for
you, then it's just Install Package.
Google it,
it's not that complicated, but
it's not that simple either.
So from there,
let's just add some really basic stuff,
like let's add a character set,
our title,
what should we call our title.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> My web page.
Looks [INAUDIBLE].
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> This webpage for mock up,
and then of course an important
thing is we're going to have
to link it to some CSS, so.
I'll link to, I'll call it style.css.
And that means I also have
to make some actual CSS.
So let's open a new tab here.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I don't want a new window.
How do I just make a new tab?
>> You can make make a new
tab by just make new file.
>> Probably, that makes sense.
Okay, so we'll just save this really
quick as, I think I said style.css.
That's there.
So hopefully that looks like it works.
Okay so
you can see both of those things.
Now for mockups.
So do you want to screen
share the mockup I sent you.
>> In that second half [CROSSTALK].
Now, lets see.
[NOISE].
>> Hello, Mr. Pasco,
feel free to ask your questions.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Cool, question.
>> Anyway, I'll just keep on going
on about what we'll be doing next.
[CROSSTALK] From the mockup, we'll be
dividing, generally we'll divide it into
a grid of 12, that grid of 12 will allow
us to actually make four side-by-side,
three side-by-side,
two side-by-side, just one.
So that's how we're going to divide up
the page into a bunch of different boxes
that boxes inside boxes.
And on an actual mockup you
might actually draw those in.
And you might literally just
drop boxes around what you want
to put as your different DIV.
And then, we'll be using basically so
that we can get the mockup.
The mockup has at most three
side by side pictures like
dividing the screen into thirds.
Generally we'll divide
it into a grid of 12,
that grid of 12 will allow us to
actually make four side-by-side,
three side-by-side,
two side-by-side, just one.
It's divisible by all those things.
It's sort of the standard for
what you'd use for something like this.
Anyway.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Let's move on then.
>> Mac, all right, yeah,
the screen wasn't-
>> Okay.
>> Log out, back in, but, we good now?
>> I'll actually copy and
paste this from the actual,
something you could have
downloaded from the course.
It's basically just,
we're going to make some CSS for
every single possible column between
one and twelve, and every row.
And we're going to be
doing that by putting
this to this end, so each column has a
specified width, and if you would find.
>> Can you increase your
text size a little bit?
>> Sure, can you see?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay
>> Fair, so hopefully this works.
The column width, this is just what you
get when you have 100 divided by 12.
And then you just double it or
not double it, but
you increase by 8.3 every time.
And so we have one through 12.
And then we have a row for
something that takes up the entire
entirety of the screen
with just the 100% here.
This margin bottom,
I suppose I could delete for the moment,
it's just specifying that we're
not have a margin here and
that we're going to be
able to flex the screen.
So if you move things in and out, it'll
be it'll keep images from overlapping.
>From not resizing basically
our text from doing the same.
So, that's where we'll start.
So, now let's start adding in
some stuff with our bodies.
So, let's I believe we may
have to make a class grid.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I forgot to do this.
So again, opening closing tags there.
I think I actually
forgot that in the CSS,
it will also need the grid that
sort of pulls everything together.
With an x width and all that stuff.
So back to CSS.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, so now that we have the grid,
let's put that in right away.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And then that's just what our,
this is basically our whole body
is going to be inside that grid.
So this is, I'm not actually sure
how necessary that technically was
because we could've just had said for
what we have for grid here is body.
If we're going to have
the entire body inside the grid,
but probably better practice.
Anyway, let's make a class for
the top, and I keep on forgetting.
Autofill can get a little annoying,
because sometimes it wants to fill in
more than you actually want.
Let's have, lets see, actually,
first let's draw some
lines around the mock up.
I'll stop screen-sharing and share
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I already stopped screen sharing, sorry.
I'll share the image I want to share
there, which will be, where are you?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So in the course you'll have noticed,
this image, at some point,
where they draw some boxes.
So you have a big box
on the outside over
here, around basically
like a type of header.
It has the Udacity logo inside
of it on the far right, and
it has a smaller box designating the,
designating the person and
sort of just a title right over here.
Then you're going to have, I don't
really know if you necessarily need
a box because that's sort of
picked up the whole row anyway.
But you kind of can have a box here and
then you'd have
another box, probably right here,
and then around all of this,
where this is this is a box,
and then each one of these would be,
also another box.
So, right here,
right here and right here.
That's sort of what we'll try to match
up here by making a grid like that.
>> So for each big horizontal block,
so it'd be one row, right?
And then for
each smaller box it'd be one column.
>> That is the idea.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So let's screen share again.
Hopefully you can still see.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Okay, so first I believe,
sorry you can see the
>> The mockup?
>> Yeah, you can't see
the mockup at the same time.
Maybe you could share that at the same
time so that they have a small tiny
little thing in the corner fto
stare at or what I'm trying to do.
Is that possible?
Can two people share something
at the same time and
have it just zoomed in on that one?
>> I think it shows mine as
a little thing in the corner.
>> Okay, well let's do that.
So we don't know really need so
first let's just make the boxes.
So first we'll have a row inside of
that will have the Udacity symbol.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Let's say that that's
about the second column.
And we'll get to about the second column
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I don't know, I keep on hoping for
it auto fill in, and it's not going to.
So we'll have one there.
We're just making these boxes with
nothing in them at the moment.
So let's make another.
This one can probably
go wherever we want it.
Somewhere between six and ten.
It's going to be right shifted,
so let's just say ten.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
But this is the title.
[BLANK AUDIO] Whereas this
is the Udacity symbol.
Completely spell, that's
a different skill I have, sorry.
Command\ or wait /.
Command/ is the thing that, well on
a Mac at least that's what automatically
makes it a comment, which is nice.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> So this is the top and
now we need another for the image.
Our big image in the middle there and
we'll just say that's another cross row.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's not turning colors for that reason.
That's our image,
now we get to another box.
Which will hold, where that
featured work sign was?
>> It should work.
>> Yep.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
But we always need the class row.
I don't really know if,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
This one doesn't really have a
And then, next we'll have our actual,
there's a problem with me
calling that one featured work.
because the top one was the featured
work, literally like the text,
that says featured work.
The next one will be what
actually is the featured work, so
we'll have to come up with
a different name for that.
>> Featured work images and-
>> Yeah, sounds good,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
We're going to need a row here,
because it needs to go all
the way across for this.
>> So is that going to put
the images and a text or?
>> We could do it either way.
We'd probably need a separate,
I think it's probably easier
to include the text with them, because
then they'll be in the same columns.
It will just be an image with text.
>> Got it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Just add that in the end.
So, the images and texts need their own
thing in the middle, so that will be
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[INAUDIBLE] So these are every four.
So we'll just say, column four for
each of them.
So the four specifies
the total width here.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And then we'll probably just cut and
paste this, copy paste this.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And I think that's actually it.
Right?
>> Yep.
Let's see.
Yeah, because you don't want
to include those colored.
>> Right.
So one problem right now is that I
don't have any way to tell what
the boxes actually look like.
So let's just make a star thing here for
that purpose.
Let's see, maybe some sort of order box.
>> Are you trying to do it?
>> I'll just make a border and make it
solid to see what everything looks like.
Okay, so now I want to actually
open this in a browser.
See what it looks like.
>> So that does not look
like much at the moment.
>> Can you share that?
>> Yeah, so.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Maybe I should have this as a separate
thing so hangouts will actually share.
Here we are.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, so this is what that
looks like at the moment,
which is probably not what
we want it to look like.
There's nothing in
these boxes right now,
so let's give our margin,
to be like 20 pixels and update it.
Okay, so that's a little bit better.
Let's instead of just
having margin bottom,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Let's just give the margin everything.
40 pixels.
Okay, that's a little bit better.
We're still having the problem that
it's kind of hard to see what in what.
It would probably be helpful if we
actually added some text to all these
things so let's, you know just.
I don't really know if screen
share works on dual screen.
[LAUGH]
>> It think does,
you just have to present
the whole screen.
>> Okay.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
Thank you.
Cool.
>> Nice.
>> Okay.
>> So.
>> Let's see here.
>> What else can I do here.so he here.
>> What else can I do them well
yeah just put some text in.
So, let's just say
Udacity and Title.
Actually, what was the name of?
It was Joe, it was like-
>> Doette.
>> Doette, yeah.
Instead of making it, wait,
was it Joe Doette or Jane?
>> Jane, Jane Doette.
>> Yeah,
they feminized the last name too.
Okay, Jane Doette.
And then image we'll just say,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> [COUGH] Image.
>> Yeah.
>> Featured work.
White space anyway.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Now I can see what actually happens.
>> Nice.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Okay, so now we see the boxes and how
they sort of are actually taking shape.
So we have and
it looks like one too many.
Well okay, so I'm guessing this is
probably the grid the whole outer one.
No the whole outer one
might be the body and
this one will be grid and
then these would be the rows.
So the rows of course they're
supposed to thing one thing two,
and thing three look
like they're supposed to.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So that's good sort of.
>> Yeah, on some of it.
>> What?
>> Is it just weird because Jane Dewit
goes all the rest of the way across?
>> Yeah, it's probably, I think for
that one we'll need to right shift it.
But it's probably easiest to
make it go all the way across.
>> Yeah.
because otherwise it might just cut off.
Actually let's experiment with that.
So right now we have it at ten.
Let's see what happens
if I have it with six.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yeah, it doesn't reach the end.
>> Yeah.
>> I think we need this to add
up to 12 so it reaches the end.
>> Got it.
>> So we're ten that will
actually reach the end.
And so we can right shift it later on.
Cool.
>> Okay, so
those are our basic steps right there.
Let's see what else do we know,
now we can actually
start putting in some images and
stuff like that which is always good.
You know actually I probably should
just keep sharing the screen.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So it's very useful.
>> Cool.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, so I know I have
the images actually I already
hosted them on Imgur, so
that should probably help.
So for instance,
here is the the Udacity image that we
can replace that word Udacity with.
So it will just be an image
with the image link.
I could have also probably
just did a hard file path but
I like posting it online better.
>From there let's get our main image for
the code and put that where
the code is supposed to be.
It should be right here.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
But I also have images for
Instead of thing one
we have this app RXI.
Instead of thing two,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
We have, what were they flowers?
And then for thing three
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Okay.
>> Let's save it and then refresh.
So we're making some progress here.
>> Nice.
>> So now it says Gendut up top.
You have our Udacity symbol
inside a lot of boxes.
[LAUGH] So it's evidently giving a
border to every image and every bit of.
It diddn't look like every bit of text.
But every image and then every div,
because you can see that this
one is inside this as well.
You can work it the same,
that amplified sunflower and
and I'm not really sure what
you call this on the right.
>> Okay,
>> It's the label.
>> Yeah.
So, I know the label was,
I think staring at this right here.
We can also add the text right here.
So, let's call that header three,
or for the BOKEH?
>> BOKEH, B-O-K-E-H.
>> Okay,
looks like it's all capitalized, too.
So we'll put that in.
And then the text underneath that,
I believe is.
It's like just a link to GitHub.
>> Yeah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
No idea if that link works or not, but
let's just see if what we did
there had any effect over there.
How nice.
It looks like we have another,
starting to fill some stuff in and
add in the text.
I'll quickly add in the text for
a bunch of these different things then.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
The same exact thing for the sunflower,
just copy and pasting that.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Should probably actually also
properly indent the stuff.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Just to make it look good.
And then the last one
I think is amplify.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So, once again,
See what our effect was there.
>> Nice.
>> Okay, adding up.
And I think Jane Doette was
different than it was originally.
It also had something else, right?
>> Front End Ninja.
>> Yeah, and
I think everything was capitalized too.
>> Yeah, it was like a subtitle.
Actually let's make that a header.
Looks really big, so we'll call it H1.
There's nothing
else that we'll call H1 so
it will help restylize it, too.
And then, I think the headers
automatically make the All caps.
>> Headers will already
make sort of a break, so
we don't have to add div or
a break statement there.
So, let's add that,
see what it looks like, cool.
We're a lot of the ways there.
>> Yeah.
>> We have a sort of HTML structure now.
So now we need to start adding CSS,
which probably means
starting to add some actual classes that
we can actually use with everything.
I know that there was the box sizing,
and
I'm pretty sure the font family, also,
I wrote this down ahead of time so
Back in our CSS,
so I suppose we can
take this margin away.
Hopefully that's
unnecessary right now and
we don't really need the, actually
let's keep the borders for now, but
I have box sizing the border box and
then the family is lotto.
I think.
At least that's what I was
told on of our website.
So, hopefully it's right.
Okay.
So, now it's
looking more like it was
probably supposed to.
I would say we're three quarters of
the way there, but we're really not.
We're really not at all.
We're three quarters of the way to the
point where you can start playing with
it on your own and
sort of making things, but for
actually truly perfectly matching it,
we're really not even that close.
Because a lot of the work is going to
get things to be exactly how you want it
with the exact amount of padding that
you wanted with the exact fonts you
want, the same colors that you want and
all that fun stuff.
So, let's see.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Let's add some classes.
So our first class will be class row and
it will also be our header.
So what's a good class name for
a header?
I don't want to, I hope,
is header already taken?
I feel like headers is
a little close to that.
>> Do like top line?
>> Top line.
Sure.
So, well have top line there and
then maybe, maybe we want this one.
The Udacity symbol is
going to be pretty simple.
It's just going to be on
an image right there.
But maybe this one we want
to stylize something in it.
So we'll call this
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Title's definitely taken, okay.
Name is also taken, okay.
[LAUGH] Let's see,
what should we call it?
[CROSSTALK]
>> [INAUDIBLE] That's also taken.
Signature.
>> Signature.
>> Probably misspelled.
>> As long as it's consistent.
>> Yeah that's all that really matters,
I suppose.
That's going to bug me.
That's okay.
Actually let's clean this up as well.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Make everything a little
bit more readable.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
These should work we should
probably give it to,
all right,
it looks pretty readable there.
So next we need our image, our center.
So maybe we'll just
call it center image.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Featured work we could just
literally call featured work.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Actually not sure what the standard
is for words like this.
Like I kind of want to use cap.
Like, snake case, or.
>> Underscore
>> Underscore.
Underscores don't screw anything up,
or dash.
[COUGH] You know, I don't work
with CSF enough compared to.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
But I would call real
programming [CROSSTALK]
>> All the grid stuff use dashes.
>> Okay,
yeah dashes are clearly safe there.
So, I wanted to thing there too,
and then this one,
and this was is featured work and
maybe we can call this.
This should all be the same, so
all these should be identical.
So,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
here we are, featured-work-data, and
that should be all the classes
that we probably need.
So let's just copy and
paste them all in.
Actually it might just be easier
to separate it for a second.
So upline
[BLANK_AUDIO]
next one was signature.
Copy and pasting, so if I have
done take one price it propagates.
>> You think so?
>> Better than it not propagating..
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Probably breaking multiple standards
here but that's all right.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
You can clean that up at the end.
This isn't a very large project.
So that should be it for
what we need right here.
Now it's time to actually
put some stuff in.
So our top line, I'm pretty
sure that we're going to want,
we are going to want
a border bottom here.
I'm looking at the thing.
So border bottom,
we're going to want it to be solid,
and I think it gives us the color,
right?
>> Yeah, yeah, it's EC Wait, hold on.
It's a different one.
>> I think it says b-b-b-b.
>> B-b-b-b, yeah.
>> Okay, let's just try it and
see what happens.
>> You see b-b-b-b.
>> It looks sort of.
Actually, let's take away these orders.
We might want to take away
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yeah okay, let's try this again,
no, that only look a lot better.
So taking away the borders
we have our grey line there,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, so let's see what we all need.
Our signature is going to
have to be right aligned.
So let's make sure that happens.
So by the line, that's good.
>From our center image,
how do you align an image?
>> [BLANK_AUDIO]
If you see just see this [INAUDIBLE],
this is what the Internet is for.
Do any students have questions
on what we've done so far?
Since we're now to the point where
we're actually going to start sort of
experimenting to try to get things.
Basically we're far enough along that we
can actually really start to experiment
to get how we want to look,
as opposed to just,
I wouldn't say blindly following along.
But we have the structure here, so
now we're really going to be playing
with the CSS to get things to
look exactly like we want them.
>> I think you want to use,
yeah, text-align.
>> It is still text-align?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, so just center.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
See if that changes anything.
[LAUGH] Let's just inspect element and
see if undoing that
makes something there.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
text-align-center seems
to be doing something.
So what happens if I say right?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That didn't seem to have any effect.
>> Hm.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
If you, if you use margin auto,
>> Okay, let's try that.
>> Actually, let's just try that here.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> And to answer your question, Dewey,
is there a limit to the number of
classes you can combine in any one div?
To my knowledge I don't think there is,
you just need to keep putting
a space and then add another class.
There's a practical limit.
>> I mean, you have to keep
them all straight in your head.
Yeah, so I, yeah,
I don't know.
I would try to use less
than five just to not
go crazy trying to keep
track of all the classes.
And if you are using that many,
that often,
you might consider just putting them
all together in a single class.
>> Yeah,
it's mostly a mental thing there.
You want things to be as easy to
understand as possible for both.
It's not just for your sake, it's, if
you ever share your code with anyone and
want to help.
Or actually, you can kind of look at
code readability doesn't just affect
other people trying to help you,
it affects you trying to pick up
your work anytime after you've
forgotten what you've done.
Which is, if you ever pick up your
work a month after you left it,
you will notice a very large
difference in where you commented well,
and sort of did classes
in a logical manner.
>From where you just sort of
packed something together and
have no idea what you're doing
when you come back to it.
because you didn't really have
a good sense of what was going on.
>> Okay, also you need to set
the width of that image, I think.
You want it to extend it
all the way across, right?
>> I've probably, yeah.
>> So it would be width 100%, I think.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Let's see if that does anything.
Does that image have that class on it?
Because it doesn't seem
to be changing anything.
>> I could have swore center-image.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
is it?
Maybe that image itself
needs to have that class
rather than-
>> The row.
>> The row, yeah.
>> Let's give it a shot.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Icon habits are carrying on over so
I guess that's okay.
Let's see if that does anything.
Yes it does.
>> Yeah, maybe too much.
>> Okay [LAUGH].
That's a big thing though, because now
we can actually play with these like
we're supposed to instead of just
blindly and hoping something works.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Width auto.
>> So it looks like it's-
>> Let's just keep it try to be centered
instead of, there,
now it stays centered.
And not trying,
I think the problem is that what we'd
want it it to do is then,
if we had width equals 100%.
>> Would it be better to
put the image inside a div?
Will that change anything?
>> Well, I think it is
technically inside of a div.
>> Right but we have a center
image be part of it, some div.
>> That did not affect anything at all.
because that was what we
were just trying to do.
>> I guess-
>> Is there a way to have a max height?
Height, yes, there is.
Maybe we can give it an actual
max height, like 500px.
Let's just make it small so
we know what the thing is.
That will probably stretch it out,
right?
>> I don't think so.
Nope, you're right.
[LAUGH]
>> Okay, so that's how we can do that.
That might be what we want.
>> Yeah, I think it is what I want.
>> Okay, so [CROSSTALK] let's
make that slightly larger.
Let's have that be 300 pixels.
Okay, that seems more like
what we're trying to get at.
>> What happens when
you re-size the window?
Nice.
>> Okay, I like it.
Seems to work.
We got that down.
Featured work, I think we wanted that
a specific color and font, right?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
What was the font again?
Or not the font, but color.
>> I think it's bb, no, bc, isn't that
the same color gray as the bcbbb?
>> Okay, let's try that out.
>> It's gotta be [CROSSTALK],
well, the share.
>> Was that what it wanted?
>> I should probably go find-
>> Yeah.
>> Yep, okay.
>> The text, the different font though.
>> Okay, any idea with the font?
Here's where we're getting into,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
More complicated thing is we're trying
to actually figure out what font it is.
>> Yeah, I don't thin kit-
>> Which could take serious time.
>> Did you already put in?
>> I put in, I thought I did.
I thought I did that for
literally everything, but.
>> Sans serif, yeah, it's all right.
Let's keep moving.
>> Okay.
>> So Julie asks,
why did that image bleed over to
the other divs when it was too big?
>> Well, it was scaling itself without
a max, it didn't have max height and so
since we specified 100% width and
tried to keep proportionality I
don't know why it decided
to keep versionality, but
I think that's just how
this browser's written.
It's probably how most
browser's are written and
we didn't have anything that...
Yeah, I don't think,
I think that's just it.
It's as though the real question is
why it didn't just push everything
else down.
>> Right.
I'm not sure.
Do you know?
>> Yeah.
>> If you think that it should,
that would be the expected behavior
is to push all the other Div's down.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
because the div should expand
to fit whatever is inside it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Yeah.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> That's a good question.
So maybe,
you want to play around a little but
this, or you keep going weak,
>> Okay,
we are actually overturn by now, but
let's just center all the text here,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Make it look a little
bit better Probably
if we ever do anything with our H1,
H2 stuff.
This looks about to be the right size,
but
Apple five should probably be bigger.
So I think that was H3, right?
So since we only have that,
we could make another class for
each of these individual things.
But right now since they're the only
h2s, and that's looks like that's it,
I'll be lazy and do this.
So font size
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[INAUDIBLE]
>> A little bit bigger.
Color, I think this was
one of the other colors.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So I'm guessing that the 747704.
Looks like it never did anything with
these featured work fonts either.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
704.
>> I think I figured it out, Luke.
>> Yeah.
>> because if you take the margin
auto out
>> Nope, nope, just kidding.
Wait, yeah.
If you take the margin auto out, then
it will cause the image to bleed over.
It actually,
it will adjust the margin of the divs
to push over into the other div.
>> Gotcha.
>> I think, yeah.
>> So-
>> Interesting.
>> Yeah, I mean can share the screen
if you guys want to see an example
of that in a second
>> So
here, and share my whole screen.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Cool, so this is what we have.
What we were running into before.
We had margin auto.
Now it's causing
a yeah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Yeah.
So do you see that still?
>> So, that's how the most tab in,
but then if you take margin auto out
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And then, we'll just adjust.
>> Looks good.
>> Yeah, okay.
>> Actually we're quite a bit
over time so I'm just going to,
like this is the gist of what you do.
>From here you play around with things.
You get things to look how you want.
You constantly experiment,
refresh, see what it looks like,
go back to back to your CSS,
experiment some more.
Basically it's a constant cycle in of,
you test, you make some changes,
you test some more, and
then you look a lot of stuff up online.
Because by this point,
no one really knows exactly what you
might be going to Google fonts
to try to find exactly what font
you want of if you can't find
it just from knowing it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
You're probably going to be playing
around with the margins, the padding,
all that stuff to get everything
exactly the right size,
probably the font sizes you're
going to be playing around with.
You're probably going to be
trying to get the spacing.
Like right now,
this h1 is quite a bit separated from,
the Jane Doette is quite a bit
separated from Front End Ninja.
And it looks like I don't really
want any space there at all.
So I would have to look
up probably putting in,
I think that would
probably be an h1 thing.
For padding or margin,
bring it down to zero or
something really small, stuff like that.
So did anyone have any final
questions before we go off there?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Guess not.
>> Okay, well I hope I hope
this was educational for
everybody and
maybe you guys even enjoyed yourselves.
But goodnight everybody.
>> Bye.
[BLANK_AUDIO]